welcome back so we're talking about data
science this kind of intro overview of
data science and I've really emphasized
that this is about asking questions and
then you know questions that you can
answer with data and this being a
feedback a feedback cycle so we're going
to start to talk about what questions
you can ask and get into a little bit
more detail soon I want to talk a little
bit about the data for now kind of the
various things we'll do with data a lot
a lot a lot of data science goes into
collecting the data storing the data
cleaning the data processing the data so
collecting curating you know storing
cleaning the data are huge aspects of
data science so a lot of database
engineering and management a lot of data
processing algorithms cleaning data
outlier identifying outliers and filling
them in what if you have missing data
you know real world data is messy and so
the collecting curating and cleaning of
data is absolutely critical I should
probably also say part of this this
feedback is identifying the right data
to start answering these questions so
you have to identify do you have the
data can you get the data and then start
collecting curating and cleaning that
data okay so this is kind of database
engineering and then what you want to do
downstream of that are things like
visualize so you want to visualize you
want to analyze and you might want to
model build models for prediction you
might want to use mum to build models
that can be used and deployed in the
real world this is kind of where machine
learning comes in so machine learning is
super exciting lots of interest in
developing these models from data but
you have to go through all of this hard
work first so tons and tons of effort
here to get to the I know for me I
really like visualizing the fun part of
vision
analyzing and modeling this is
interesting in fun too but this is kind
of you know goes in this in this
direction and there's feedback though at
every step once you visualize the data
you've been collecting you might decide
that you need to modify your data
collection or the way that you're
storing or you know to ask different
questions once you start analyzing and
modeling again there might be feedback
loops and all levels of this process and
this is not kind of a static
architecture this is a dynamic process
again in the hands of expert humans
teams of humans asking questions that
can be answered with data so I think of
data science as kind of data-driven
inquiry or the science of how to to do
that data-driven inquiry and I'll be
blunt
a lot of times when I talk to companies
for example in consulting they spend a
lot of time and effort a majority of
their time and effort in this side and
this kind of data engineering and I've
heard all kinds of analogies and stories
you're gonna build a data Lake and
you're gonna have all these data rivers
going into data Lake you know this big
warehouse where you're gonna hold all of
your data and I must caution you if you
don't invest in the analysis the
modeling the visualization you're gonna
find yourself up data creek without data
paddle okay so you need to do this this
is critical but you also need to be
investing in kind of the analytics and
the modeling and these these rich things
you can do with your data and I think
visualization is is so important because
we're inherently visual you know beings
and this visualization also is all about
communication so if you have a great
idea but you can't communicate it to
your boss or to your team you know it
wasn't that great of an idea and so
visualization is is also a critical
aspect of how how this feedback feedback
cycle works and that's that's another
kind of point I want to make is that
this is not data science is not about
the data it's not about the algorithms
it's about the people and the tea
and the problems you're gonna solve it's
questions you're asking it's problems
you want to solve problem solving and
it's an inherently collaborative art so
data science involves teams of people
collaborating so teams of experts and
you know in the in the traditional model
of an expert you might have you know we
call these t-shaped people so you have
some breadth you know not just one thing
but lots of things and you have a lot of
depth in one area
maybe this depth is in designing you
know Automotive aerodynamic streamlined
bodies or maybe this is in aircraft
design or space mission design or
whatever it is that you're interested
that you do you know for me it's fluid
flow control and fluid modeling but
increasingly what we're going to find in
the future in these teams of data
scientists or sorry data scientists on
teams problem-solving teams is that
people will need to develop a second
depth area in data science so this is
what people call pie-shaped people
pie-shaped experts so you still need
your breath and your domain expertise
but now you have this kind of data
science expertise and so I really want
to emphasize data scientists are not
just going to be sitting across a
firewall from the people collecting the
data and solving the problems you want
data scientists on your team in the room
helping you make decisions in fact
ideally you want the experts who are
collecting the data and doing the
problem-solving to have data science
expertise so this is going to be like
computer literacy you don't just have
everybody who solves problems and then
people who only under you know only a
few people who understand how computers
work and a firewall you have your team
of expert problem solvers and they all
have a basic degree of computer literacy
and then you have kind of experts who
are on the team okay and that's how we
see kind of data science evolving
being a core functionality that your
whole team you're gonna have to
integrate this into into your team okay
other things that are really important
are these aspects of reproducibility
reproducibility in science there has
been a crisis that lots of results that
had been published when other groups of
scientists try to reproduce them they
can't and that means there's something
wrong in the way that we are conducting
and conveying scientific data and so
this idea of reproducibility is really
ubiquitous we want the processes that we
spend our lives developing and improving
to be reproducible by others we want
reliability of the things we learn and
the things we optimize and design and so
reproducibility is also critical in data
science how do you collect enough data
that your processes are reproducible
that you're staying you have standards
in some sense okay so lots of lots of
things to think about
it's about this feedback you have to do
a lot of work collecting your data and
curating and cleaning but then you get
to analyze and visualize and communicate
you get to solve problems with data on
teams and hopefully your teams of
experts are not kind of segregated into
domain experts and data scientists but
you have people who have this kind of
mixed capability of domain expertise and
data science expertise okay we're going
to keep going into more depth we're
going to talk about the various aspects
of this in more detail thank you